vamos a suponer que tú estás en un
puesto que vende naranjas y está que
tenemos aquí como puedes ver es la curva
de la demanda del puesto de naranjas o
tu curva del beneficio marginal o
inclusive podríamos llamarle la
disposición del pago que recibirás que
dice que para los primeros 100 kilos de
naranjas el precio de venta por
kilogramo es cercano a 3 pesos ahora
bien después de los 100 kilogramos en el
101 kilogramos el precio por kilogramo
será un poco menor y esto es la
disposición de pago o el beneficio
marginal de en el aumento de un
kilogramo
ahora bien vamos a suponer que tú
decides fijar el precio en dos pesos y
entonces puedes llegar a vender 300
kilogramos de naranjas en cada semana lo
que quiero que pensemos en este vídeo es
cuál va a ser nuestro total del
excedente del consumidor que tú
consumidor va a obtener y bueno en el
vídeo pasado observamos que el excedente
del consumidor lo podemos definir como
cuánto beneficio obtuvieron por encima y
más allá de lo que pagaron así que por
ejemplo la persona que compró no sé
digamos exactamente 100 kilogramos de
naranjas por 100 kilogramos
pagó dos pesos pero realmente si solo
fuera él tendría que pagar tres pesos
con 30 centavos pero solo pago dos pesos
así que el respectivo beneficio del
consumidor fue de un peso con 30
centavos es decir el excedente al
consumidor va a ser 3 pesos con 30
centavos menos 2 pesos que es un peso
con 30 centavos así que la persona que
compró 100 kilogramos tiene un excedente
del consumidor de un peso con 30
centavos y bueno como nosotros queremos
el total del excedente del consumidor
bastaría hacerlo para cada uno de los
kilogramos es decir 101 kilogramos y
entonces kilogramos etcétera que
esencialmente es el área que bueno
esperen primero voy a hacer un zoom para
que se vea mucho más claro lo que les
quiero contar fíjense bien en este
rectángulo que tenemos aquí este
rectángulo es el zoom de la línea que
habíamos remarcado antes el cual tiene
de ancho un kilogramo y vamos a fijarnos
qué es lo que pasa con este rectángulo
lo primero que quiero que veas es que
esta línea punteada es el precio que
fijamos de dos pesos y este de aquí es
nuestra curva de la demanda
la cual tiene una cierta pendiente y en
este punto vale tres pesos con 30
centavos entonces nosotros lo que
hicimos fue restar tres pesos con 30
centavos menos los dos pesos del precio
fijo y obtuvimos un peso con 30 centavos
que va a ser esta altura de aquí por lo
tanto ya podemos sacar el área de este
rectángulo un peso con 30 centavos que
multiplica a un kilogramo nos dio lo que
obtuvimos que era un peso con 30
centavos del excedente del consumidor
por lo tanto nuestro excedente del
consumidor que es el área este detecta
ángulo es de un peso con 30 centavos y
bueno podríamos extender esta idea
cuando nosotros tenemos 101 kilogramos y
cuando nosotros tenemos 102 kilogramos y
también que nosotros tenemos 103
kilogramos o cuando nosotros tenemos 99
kilogramos y llenar esta parte de
rectángulos es decir nosotros lo que
estamos sacando es el área que está
abajo de la curva de demanda y arriba de
la curva del precio igual a 2
esencialmente lo que queremos es esta
área que voy a colorear en este preciso
momento y si nosotros estamos
familiarizados con el cálculo nosotros
sabemos
esta es la idea de la integral más aún
aquí tenemos una curva de la demanda que
es una recta pero si nosotros tuviéramos
una curva de la demanda que no fuera una
recta entonces lo que se hace es que
esos estamos listos vamos a ser
sumamente pequeños cada vez más y más y
más delgados más pequeños y por lo tanto
nosotros obtenemos la idea de integral y
con la integral nosotros podemos
calcular el área bajo una curva pero
regresando el problema en el que estamos
ahorita nosotros lo que tenemos es una
curva de la demanda que es una línea
recta y por lo tanto conseguir el área
arriba del precio que fijamos para el
preso igualados y abajo de la curva de
demanda es calcular esencialmente esta
área que tenemos aquí y bueno no es
necesario que tú entiendas perfectamente
todo lo que hay detrás de todo esto la
idea de integrando es una idea sencilla
sin embargo lo que yo quiero que
entiendas es que estamos calculando
estos pequeños rectángulos es decir el
excedente del consumidor para cada uno
de los distintos kilogramos que nosotros
tenemos y entendiendo a eso nos damos
cuenta que el área que tenemos que
calcular es esencialmente el área de
este triángulo
ahora bien como calculamos el área de un
triángulo pues primero hay que fijarnos
en la base la base es de 0 a 300
kilogramos lo que nos da 300 kilogramos
la base es de 300 kilogramos y ahora que
fijarnos en la altura para fijarnos en
la altura tenemos un precio de 2 pesos
hasta 4 pesos y esto es 2 pesos dense en
cuenta que es el área de un triangulito
porque tenemos una ecuación lineal si no
fuera una ecuación que me dibuja una
línea recta si fuera una curva entonces
lo que nosotros necesitaríamos sería la
integral por lo tanto es de 2 pesos a 4
pesos hay 2 pesos y entonces ya es muy
fácil sacar el área de un triangulito es
base por altura sobre 2 un medio de la
base por la altura un medio que
multiplica a la base que nosotros
dijimos que era 300 kilogramos entonces
un medio que multiplica a 300 kilogramos
y a su vez que multiplica a la altura
del triángulo que eran 2 pesos por
kilogramo no si 2 pesos por kilogramo y
ahora si si nosotros hacemos las
respectivas cuentas kilogramos con
kilogramos se va y me queda un medio por
2 que es 1 por 300 me da
cientos y pues las unidades son pesos
entonces 300 pesos y ya con esto
terminamos porque el total del excedente
el consumidor es el área de este
triángulo que tenemos aquí que acabamos
de calcular que son 300 pesos